Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Google Feud!
Now, in the last video you watched me laugh like an idiot,
at absolutely nothing,
for about six minutes straight!
But then you decided that that wasn't enough.
So you demanded more!
Well, surprise! Surprise!
I'm an idiot all the time.
So we're gonna play more but this time
but we're not gonna stick to just one category like an idiot
we're gonna go and deviate into other places.
Like questions which is also have good sth- sth- stuff
Is it possible to suck your own dick?
Aw goddammit!!
I told myself I wasn't gonna do this!
Is it possible to clone yourself?
Is it possible to FLY?
Is it possible to...
(splutters)
...give birth to a genie?!
Fuck!
How old do I have to be to work at Starbucks?
How old do I have to be to work at 'Youtrube'?
How old do I have to be to work at RedTube?
(laughing) How old do I have to be to work at RedTube?
Dammit...
Everything tastes...
guud...
bad...
...like semen!!
(laughing)
I'm so sorry, I don't mean for it to go this way...
Everything tastes like BALLS!
Will my dog eat my...
Will my dog eat my cat?
Will...
Will my dog eat my car?
Will my dog eat my food?
Will my dog eat my pet rat?
Eat my BABY?
Eat my DEAD BODY??
Oh god!
Do astronauts POOP?
Do astronauts HAVE SEX?
WHAT!? That's what I wanna know!!
Do astronauts...
masturbate?
Dammit!
Can I eat my... didn't I get this one?
Can I eat my potato?
Can I eat my dog?
Oh god no!
Can I eat my cat?
Can I eat my pet named Steve?
FUCK!
Ah shit, can I eat... my... car?
Dammit
SPERM!?
AW COME ON!!
I was actually going to think that
but I didn't want to go that road.
Why do adults have nipples?
Why do adults have belly buttons?
WHY DO ADULTS HAVE TAXES?
ergh
Is it painful...
Is it painful to
put a dick in your butt?
(sniff)
(anger laugh)
Is it painful to be an idiot?
(sigh)
Is it painful to die? (laughing)
Do fish ever
explore space? (laughing)
Uugh
man I'm doing badly
How to get rid of your
enormous penis...
How to get rid of your acne
WHAT!?
Can dogs learn to FLY?
What?!
Can dogs learn to sit?
Can dogs learn to drive a car?
Can dogs learn to... speak?
Yeah
Can dogs learn to
...feel love?
Dammit
What happens when you mix alcohol ...and bad decisions? (laughing)
What happens when you mix ALCOHOL
and excessive masturbation?
Is my bird a terrorist?
(Laughs uncontrollably)
(sniff)
(more giggles)
oh goddamn it
Ah, I don't know why that wasn't one of them.
Is my bird...
on fire?
Is my bird gay?!
What?!
How is that one of them? (laughing)
Is my bird Jacques?
fuck
Is my bird pregnant? (laughing)
(sniff)
I don't think you understand birds
How do you fake
a death?
a murder?
an orgazzmo?
Whaat?!
I guess everyone just already knows how to do that...
What is the number for "Times I gave a fuck"
What happened to Markiplier?
(Laughing uncontrollably)
(sniff)
I don't fucking know
One day I woke up and got really stupid...
and then I started making YouTube videos
Why is my boyfriend so nonexistant?
Why is my boyfriend so jacksepticeye?  (laughing)
Is there a law against-
Is there a law against eating balls? (laughing)
Is... is it bad to be Hitler (uncontrollable giggling)
Is it bad... to kill your family?
When... when is a good time to masturbate? (uncontrollable giggling)
Can you die from eating too much dick?
(sniff)
AAAAAAAAA
I gotta stop
I gotta...
Can you die from eating too much poon?
(sniff)
That's not better
Can you die from eating too much weed?
Can you die from eating too much FOOD?
Can you die from eating
too much human? (laughing)
Is there... Is there such a thing
as an underground race of potato people?
Dammit!
We're going to rise again!
Does Santa Claus have slaves? (laughing)
Does Santa Claus have
a (laughing) huuuhooohooohooohoohooohuge...
factory?
Wh- Why is my goldfish plotting against me?
How much does it cost to buy... a house?
...a car?
Aaaaaaaay-- dog?
A cat?
cat? Ah fuck
How much does it cost to buy
a death star?
FUCK!!
A s- a star!?
Why why-
Why am I afraid of
my sexuality
(laughing like a madman)
Why am I afraid of the dark?
Why am I afraid of spiders?
Why am I afraid of... huh... shadows?
Why am I afr- Why am I afraid?
Aagh, what am I afraid of?
Why am I afraid of mannequins?
fuck
From what age can babies fight to the death? (uncontrollable giggling)
From what age can babies drive a tank? (uncontrollable giggling continues)
From what age can babies subscribe to Markiplier? (more uncontrollable giggling)
(sniff)
(giggles)
What the Fuck is a bumbo? (uncontrollable giggling)
Is it okay to swim with Jeff Goldbloom? (giggling)
I just don't trust that guy...
Should I quit YouTube?
God damn it. I-I don't know why this game makes me laugh so much!
I don't know..
It's cause I just get to unleash my stupidity
And I have a lot of it and I try to hold it in
And it just comes out in bursts
(Scream and slaps face) huuuuuh! aaAaaAaaAAaHh!!
Okay
So thank you everybody so much for watching.
This is google feud.
I don't- I don't know
I don't know what more you want from me...
I just- I can't do more. I can't do it.
Ohhh so thank you everybody so much for watching!
You can see the other video if you haven't seen it already.
I'll put it in the description or-
Check out more non-stupid videos that I've done!
There aren't many but they're out there, trust me.
Somewhere.
Somewhere, they're out there.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always! I will see YOU...
In the next video.
BUH-BYE!!